been on A4 right and the queen is doing  a good job on d8  yeah keeping also still an eye on G5  after all  maybe but but then anyway I was thinking  that maybe white should have just stayed  and my mistakes goes for Queen take G5  and that's it that's another big problem  and everything bleeds doubt 11 58 no  magnus's clock  yeah this is not looking good  black can even actually just trade  queens and I think that's what he wants  yeah yeah he trades Queenston his pawns  will just inexorably move towards yeah  for example King H2 you have adjusted  the queen to F6 for example 27 also yeah  it is yeah it depends no because Queen  F6 lands into looking for yes exactly I  mean those tactics one should pay  attention so yes we we go back to  E7